um men are generally quick to check
other men when they're doing the wrong
thing yeah 100 yeah i don't believe in
that statement like at all wait could
you you don't think so nah man's group
chat quick i don't think so what does
that mean what do you mean like wait i'm
sorry can you repeat what you just said
yeah i said men are generally quick to
change the mind men are generally quick
to check their man like their friend or
whatever if he's doing something wrong
in terms of how he relates to people
what he's doing financially or whatever
she looks like she disagrees maybe
financially but like there's even
campaigns there's literally campaigns
like of
men cut like as we're talking about
earlier like trying to chirps girls in
the street and us feeling unwanted and
man then just sitting there watching
their friends doing it and you can see
the females uncomfortable yeah why don't
you check him then
i'll tell you why it's not like majority
of times like we do check them but then
people that do it
don't care like we we do our hardest to
check them like i've checked a lot of my
friends as long as you do no no i'll
tell you why because
who he's checking
is not dressed appropriately
he doesn't come correct so you're saying
she deserves it she deserves to be
confronted or have a guy come up to her
when she's alone is late at night
you got a group of men around a single
woman kind of yes yes you think it's hot
bruh you think it's time for the amount
of time it kind of kind of dude
i'll tell you why i'll tell you why i'll
tell you why
[Music]
i'll tell you where
because
if it was the other way around
that's how it would be for men in a
sense what do you mean in the sense of
this
if men was the one that was
in the position like how how women have
structured it in terms of it's okay for
us to do it but it's not okay for you to
do you think women corner man and you've
already said multiple times during
during this podcast that you've said
that a man is stronger than a woman so
you know you and your friends going
around a single female is going to
naturally intimidate her but that's okay
because of what she's wearing how many
times have you been hit before by a man
multiple no when you say multiple how
many times because i can't count i've
said i've been in abusive relationships
i've been hit multiple times yeah but
okay but when i say this i mean in the
sense of this
i think a man is more has more to be
scared of another man than a woman to be
scared of a man like it's more likely
for a man to to hit another man than for
a man no not these days no and i will
tell you that because men are men are
more comfortable going after women
because they know that the women cannot
fend for themselves exactly so they're
not man enough to go for a man so
they're going to go for a woman because
oh wait what i don't know i see what
they're saying because like we could
targets like that's how they like they
see as weaker targets but now everyone's
just like like back then there was like
mad fights like pb safari all the time
but now it's kind of like in them
circumstances like we've been like
taught to like find another way around
that so like if we see someone stronger
than us we're not really gonna try to
test them anymore okay okay if you was
to walk down the road naked do you think
someone has the the right to stop you
and ask you if you if you want to but
you're not who's walking around
it doesn't work wait wait wait
and i could see every single
i can see everything like you're not
you're not leaving anything for the
imagination like just because i see is
see-through now is see-through but
because it's a leggings now it's okay
but i've seen everything nah you don't
why are you taking it there like why
does your brain instantly sexually
because i have testosterone and you have
estrogen it's like you saying why do i
have to why did you have so me walking
down
me walking down the street in a dress
instantly makes because i look feminine
means you can come up to me and make me
feel intimidated because that's
literally wrong i don't think you should
feel intimidated i feel that girls i
should feel empowered no
i believe girls feel intimidated even
when men don't want to intimidate them
so i'll give it to you like this i'm
just walking down the road chirps and
you you feel intimidated you can't tell
me that when the girl when the when the
woman walks across the road because i'm
walking behind her with a handbag and
she crossed the road quickly that's my
fault
but you know as a man you are bigger you
are stronger it's later let me finish
yeah but it's late at night and you know
by you walking close you don't know what
the [ __ ] she's been through okay and you
might make her feel uncomfortable by
walking close to her so how do you know
that guy is not going to be the guy that
saves her so you've told me to f off now
yeah and you've gone around the corner
wait hold on you've gone around the
corner and an another guy the best way
to stop with one guy sounds kind of
personal bro how about god
it's like if he was in trouble are you
one of them guys that goes up to girls
on the street late at night and chaps is
them speaking to them it depends yeah it
depends if she's looking crazy pretty
enough if she's looking uh like
available enough yeah hand on my heart i
beg you
check yourself before you do that
because you have no idea how
uncomfortable or scared
or afraid she doesn't know you remember
you you can be a lovely i know we've had
like disagree i can see you're a nice
guy but she doesn't know you okay she
doesn't know you and you approaching is
intimidating there's a way you can go
about i don't know obviously how you
address a woman but if you're aware of
the time setting she's alone the
surroundings if you're with multiple
people there's a way if you want to
charge her to do it politely without
intimidating that's that's so unfair
i'll tell you why because you guys don't
want to do the chirps in so okay if you
did the chirps in
please be guaranteed for 100 women
wouldn't stop men at two o'clock in the
morning four o'clock in the morning two
it doesn't matter what time it will be
for them so if okay so as a man you
gotta remember
i didn't have a choice whether or not i
was born a man or not okay so it's not
the fact that i'm stopping you in the
middle of the night because if a girl
stopped you in the middle of the night
you stop and talk to her it's the fact
that i'm a man so now you're being
sexist because you're not being sick
hold on i'll tell you why you're being
sexist because you've already decided
what i'm like before you even know me so
it's like okay it's like
you don't see that sexist no i'm saying
that from
you've already said countless times how
men are stronger bigger all of these
things so if it's night time naturally
it's a more vulnerable setting you
you're aware of the power you hop you're
aware of the power you hold you're
making excuses because i'm not making it
you're you're you're you're you're
you're being him ladies
i don't agree with what he's saying like
thank you i do get what you're saying
but it's it's unreasonable because
men are biologically stronger like males
males are not men but males are
biologically stronger and if you're
seeing this and back to the original
statement if it's
you're saying no but i'm not saying that
i'm saying that girls don't like a guy
that's shorter than them so the guy
that's cause it doesn't matter if you're
shorter or
not because no it doesn't matter if
you're shorter or not you're
biologically stronger than you're
missing my point you're missing my point
i'm saying
i don't know
i get your point
though i didn't even finish though yeah
yeah because he did just ask me so back
to the original how we started this this
sentence right now or this dialogue you
were talking about guys checking your
friends so in this scenario because
you're saying on a one-on-one thing
you're what we originally talking about
is one uh a woman and a guy is with his
friends and then it goes up to her so
checking it in that sense you're like
it's two different things but it doesn't
matter if a guy or shorter talk a male
is still going to be biologically
stronger than a female so yeah okay
what do you think about what he said
i was going back to what he was saying
about checking the guys you say you
check guys but you guys are also talking
about women checking other women but do
you do the checking in public too or do
you do it one-on-one and in public or
just both i do both because like
because like okay so if i'm with someone
and they start moving like barabooki
like there's a goat there there's like a
crowd of people and he starts acting up
i'm also gonna get real know for his
actions so like at the moment i have to
call it out but it's not like i'm not
caught i'm not calling it out just
because it's gonna make me seem bad i'm
also calling it out because obviously
like i have sisters and things of that
nation i can't like let that run like i
can't be friends with someone who does
that [ __ ] and then expect like when it
happens to my sister and she's like i'm
just going to be like okay then
yeah and to be honest that whole um 2am
situation any anything that would make a
girl feel
really uncomfortable or you know make
her feel unsafe
anything like that would definitely not
fly with me i'll definitely have to
check my mind in that kind of situation
and also like if one of my friends comes
up to me he's like he he saw a girl at 2
a.m
went up to her i'll be like what's wrong
with you because first of all like you
have to understand like a lot is there
now a time limit where you can't allow
you're not allowed to check girls
this generation is mad it's just like we
associate nighttime activity with like
less protection like people would go off
they do drugs they they so why is she
outside then because maybe it's nothing
if it's that dangerous why is she
outside she's trying to go home no no if
it's that dangerous why is she outside
what if she just came home from work but
why is she working where she has to
leave and come out in dangerous times
she has no choice
no i'm not saying that i'm saying this
you know fully well it's not dangerous
because okay i'll tell you why in the
sense of this
[Laughter]
i'll tell you why i'll tell you why
i'll tell you why i'll tell you why it's
not dangerous because
i'll tell you why you have you have okay
i me as a man
they will never unders you would never
understand because you're a woman you're
allowed to hit a man and not expect
something to come back it's
not yet exactly it's different you could
hit a man
and he wouldn't hit you back in most
circumstances well if he hit you back
and there's another man around he's
going to get hit
that's just standard yeah but if i'm if
i'm if i'm on the road wait did you just
say if if there are two guys around and
the woman hits the man that the other
man is going to hit the other man no
that's not what i said i said it's going
to check it
the guy is going to check the the guy
that hits the woman
no one is going to check the woman that
hits the man
i have multiple times i've never seen a
man
listen guys there have been um there
have been
social studies done on this that have
been filmed and there have been men and
women both in the street
and
the woman has slapped the man and people
be like oh my god it's crazy
but then the man has just been in
woman's face shouting at her and he's
been checked it's been done multiple
times women are more likely to be seen
as the victim
in those situations do you know what i'm
saying and men are more likely to be
seen as aggressive that's the truth but
i then that goes back to everyone
knowing that men are women females
females are biologically weaker than
that's your facade it's not a facade
a man's weakness is the facade of his
strength a woman's strength is the
facade of her weakness if she if if
she's acting weak
that's where she gets her strength in
don't act weaker at me because you're
not because you said you want equality
you work the same you're strong as us
when it comes to like certain stuff it's
like no we could do it we're girls
there's girl power we could do this but
when you want to and you want to switch
off that little thing it's like oh we're
innocent we don't do nothing oh if you
was that endangered you wouldn't walk at
two o'clock in the morning in london
with a short skirt on and drunk out your
head bopping from side to side london is
one of the safest places in the world
right now what i am saying to you is
you guys are not prepared to go up to
men and chirps them
you do not want a man that's shorter
than you so when a guy that is taller
than you and knows he's your type he's
going to come to you